[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's the hall of fame coach nbc football
night in america
joining us on the program good to see
you again tony let me start there
when did we start to speed up the
process of when we evaluate a
quarterback whether he can be your
franchise quarterback or not
well i think it really has been in the
last 10 years maybe since since i left
because i know that was a situation
where you drafted a guy
and you had to see i went to tampa in
1996 trent dilfer had been there two
years
and richmond okay part of the deal was
hey we've got to see
if this number six pick in the draft can
pan out so you aren't going to be
evaluated
until we find that out you're not going
to be evaluated as a coach
but we've got to find out and that was
our game plan for
for two years and uh it seems like we
have left that
if i get a chance to pick another guy
and this guy is a
more solid franchise quarterback let's
go
you have to have a quarterback to win
there's no question about that but some
of these guys need some time dan to
progress but have you seen enough of
daniel jones
no i haven't because i see sometimes
like last night where
gosh you missed a couple of easy
touchdown passes you end up throwing
interceptions when we had everything set
up
but then i saw some other games i saw
last year he played a beautiful game
against the bucks and beat them
um so you're going to have a little bit
of that peyton manning was
i think four years in the league when we
got there to to indianapolis
and he had a 500 record so let's not
say that you know in two years you're
going to see everything you need to see
that play at the end of the game the
call on the field and then they picked
up the flag what would you have
done i don't like that because
uh john perry said well past
interference has to be clear and obvious
well the official knew that when he
threw the flag he knows the rule for
past interference so
i have to see clear and obvious before i
throw the flag i throw it
and then someone else tells you no
that's not really clear and obvious
the offensive past interference on choi
lolo was the same thing was that clear
and obvious
uh no we had a conversation about that
same thing happened in the green bay
minnesota game they picked up a flag
that was clearly penetrated it was
thrown and then somehow the flag gets
picked
up so no i don't like those it feels
like when in doubt throw the flag
and then let the uh home office of the
nfl officials
get in touch with you and say you know
what pick the flag up or no that is past
interference
as a coach do you have a problem if the
officials on the field
are probably not making the final
decision on some of these calls
i don't have a problem if it goes that
way the whole time if that's our system
let's do that
but the two bogus holding penalties that
they had earlier in the game
let the home office look at that and say
hey you know what that really wasn't
holding
if we're going to do that on everything
great but don't just do it on the last
play of the game
when five other plays could have made a
difference as well so
if we're going to do it let's do it all
the time what kind of questions remain
for the buccaneers in brady
i think it's a matter of timing and just
consistency in building that
you see tom looks so much more
comfortable he's got
a better connection my question is we
saw how long it took with gronk gronk
took a year off
and the first part of the season what
was everybody saying oh gronk's not the
same tom doesn't have that with him and
now we're seeing that connection after
eight or nine weeks
antonio brown has been off how many
years a year and a half now
how long is it going to take to get that
connection with him and everybody says
oh yeah he looks great and he's in shape
but tom brady is going to need to see
him come out of routes how is he going
to run this route against this
what are we going to do and so is it
going to take another six weeks to get
adjusted to antonio brown i think
they've got a great team right now and i
hope this
this kind of experiment with antonio
doesn't set that back a little bit would
you have brought him in
i probably wouldn't have because i would
have wanted to hear some contrition
first so i'm sorry and i'm different now
and i've changed i believe in second
chances you know that dan
but i also believe people need to repent
and say you know what
i was wrong so yeah what i did in new
england what i did
in oakland what i did in in pittsburgh
that that was wrong what i've done and
i've been out i've missed the game
and i want to come back and i'm going to
change if i hear that then i'm all for
it but i haven't heard that yet what
team are you all in on right now
nobody i think everybody has some issues
uh rodney harris and i had this debate
on sunday night oh kansas city you know
they're the team to be
well kansas city has some defensive
issues
as well i love their offense and where
they're going but
i see some of those things creep up and
pittsburgh is undefeated but we see
leads being blown i saw coverages where
i couldn't understand what was
happening nobody's around willie sneed
and
so that that's not great but then you
see the plays that they make
to make things happen so yeah they've
got a lot of talented guys i love their
receiving core now
i love ben being in control but they've
they've got some issues so i think
that's just where we are uh fundamental
football
time management all those things have
we've lost that
dealing with this pandemic and not
practicing so
i think somebody's going to emerge here
in the next few weeks
um but we're still in that
discovery phase i think he's the hall of
fame coach tony dungy on loan from nbc
football night america
it feels like the game is all about
offense
you can't have too much offense the
seahawks wanting to get more offense in
there
kansas city using their draft pick to
get more offense in there
is that where we are right now in the
nfl that
you know can you build a defensive
minded
team that is a super bowl contender
i don't think in this salary cap era and
the way you have to do it
there's not going to be a legion of boom
that leads a team to
a championship with defensive play uh
you're going to have some good defenders
you're going to have a defense that
helps you win
but you got to have a quarterback you
got to have an offense that can score
and i think if i were coaching now i
would go down that
that road hey i do i want antonio brown
to add to my three other play making
receivers because the more i can score
the better off we're going to be the
rules uh say that
uh everything lends itself to that and
when you have to decide how to spend
your money who you're going to pay
you need to pay those offensive guys no
doubt but when you had peyton
did peyton always want you to draft an
offensive player
no not necessarily but we we did uh but
that's one of the things bill polin told
me we're always going to feed the
monster
so you got on defense you got to make it
work we've got to get guys like robert
mathis
in the fourth round who are great
players but it comes down the line
in the first round i remember boy there
was a mock draft and everybody's saying
my second year there we got to go
defense and bill said hey dallas clark
is going to help us win championships we
got to take him
we were number 27 26 on defense
and we fed the monster and joseph had
died
and and we kept doing that and we got
enough offensive guys
we had to find the defensive guys and we
got some some guys
kind of under the radar but offense was
going to win it for us
and i think we're even farther along in
that now in this era what would you do
with jimmy garoppolo if you're the 49ers
i think i would stay with him and he's
played some games where
you know that that stretched last year
when they're as good as anybody in
football
uh when they run the football and when
they're playing defense jimmy garoppolo
is very good and there's a lot of
quarterbacks like that
so i've got one that i know can take me
to the super bowl
i think i would stay with it but you've
got to have that
that core around him no doubt but if
you're bill belichick
would you at least inquire about trading
garoppolo back to new england
no because i think when you let him go
that told me something right there
uh if i thought jimmy garoppolo was the
next tom brady
i'm not letting him go no matter what
anybody says or what happens so
that that gave me a little buyer beware
when they let them go new england
doesn't let good players just go for
free hey
i want to do you a favor san francisco
he's a really great quarterback
um good luck no that
you know he had some concerns and i
don't know what those were but
i think that ship has sailed well i
don't think tom
wanted the competition there
i don't know about that even if that's
true bill belichick doesn't care about
people's feelings
okay there's a lot of people that had
suggestions for how they should do
things
and belichick is going to do it his way
and if he really thought
hey we'll make this work tom if jimmy
garoppolo
is the heir apparent he's the next guy
you're 40 years old
and i i i know that you've been with me
and we've won all these super bowls but
this guy can get me to five more super
bowls in the next 10 years
i think your feelings are going to have
to get hurt tom
how long do you stay with cam newton i i
think you ride it out this year
you you built this around a running
attack and all of those things
and uh this is the way you can win maybe
you can turn it around and get it going
if not you know you're not gonna be able
to go to jared stidham and all of a
sudden turn this into a drop back
don't you need to find out if he can
play tone or do you think belichick
knows what he has in jarrett student
i i think he kind of understands that
otherwise he wouldn't have gone out to
get cam newton yeah
um yeah i think that again when you made
that move that told me yeah i like
jared stidham but i'm not sold on him
yet
what you know and you had edrin james
who's a hall of famer
but i wonder about that position as we
move forward
you know you you have to be pretty much
a guy who can run but also catch the
ball out of the backfield
uh where where do you place up your
priorities on on your running back in
the draft
i think you you look at what people have
done look at san francisco
if they can put debo samuel back there
and and make yards and run the ball well
and you look at kansas city and guys we
thought oh lashawn mccoy and then
he kind of got nicked up and damian
williams went in there and now he's
opted out and what are we going to do i
would draft clyde edwards a lair and
um you know i we kind of went through
that with edgerrin
bill poland came to me i'll never forget
it dan he said you know we can pay edgar
and he deserves it he's a great player
he's been the heart and soul of us
but if we sign him to what he is going
to command
we're not going to be able to resign
reggie wayne and dallas
clark and dwight friendly so the better
way to go would be to let edgerron go
we'll draft the young running back we'll
get them at the
rookie rate and we're going to get
maurice jones drew or joseph a die
and that's exactly what happened so
um you know i think that's the way you
go down the road you say hey if i'm
i'm kansas city yeah i'd love to have
that great back but you know what
i'll get one i'll get one in the draft
would you trade for j.j watt would you
trade him if you're the texans uh
i i might think about it now depending
on what i could get because my
season and next year is going to be a
rebuilding year and i don't have high
draft choices
so uh as painful as it would be and
you're
giving up a big time play maker to
recoup
some of that and to be able to build my
offense i might have to think about it
i don't know what he's worth like
a second maybe a third round pick do you
even get that for
j.j watt you might get a second and
somebody like seattle now they they got
carlos dunlop but uh
if jj were dangling out there
and you thought man i can get to the
super bowl that one guy who can rush the
passer maybe get that one second af
nfc championship game that i need you
you think about that we did that booger
mcfarland
we needed a run stopping nose tackle we
had a lot of injuries up front
and we said hey second round pick i know
booger he can fit in the system and he
played great for us and helped us win a
super bowl was it worth the second round
or you bet it was
it's great to talk to you again hope
things are well with the family there
and uh my best to
everybody on football night in america
all right sounds good dp always great to
talk to you
that's tony dungy hall of fame head
coach